>> Female Presenter: My name is Camille Hearst.
I'm a product managing
marketer at YouTube.
And I'm very excited to be here
today with the cast and crew of Awkward Black
Girl.
Let's give
them a warm welcome.
[applause and cheering]
>> Female Presenter: Really excited about
the turnout so thank you all for
coming.
What we'll do today is have a conversation
for
about half of the time.
Then we'll screen an episode.
Episode five: the party.
[laughter] I can see a lot of
you have seen it already.
>>Audience member: Love it
>>Female Presenter: And then we will go into
Q and
A open to the floor.
There's a mic over here that we ask
you to come and speak into the mic because
we have people
on VC which is video conferencing for those
out in
YouTube land.
We're also recording this for YouTube
later that's also why we want you to use the
mic.
So
thanks for coming.
Let's go ahead and get started.
For
those of you who are not familiar, Awkward
Black Girl is
the show about J, an awkward black girl who
navigates
the mine field of love, friendship and office
politics.
The series began in January 2011 so earlier
this year and
now consists of 12 episodes.
At the beginning they
struggled with having enough money to continue
but were
able to raise over 56 thousand dollars through
an online
kick starter campaign that they promoted quite
a bit
through YouTube.
And to date, Awkward Black Girl has 3
million views and counting so quite an accomplishment.
So first I'd like to ask you all to introduce
yourself
and who you are in real life and who you are
on the show.
>> Issa: So my name is Issa Ray and I'm just
a film maker,
writer, aspiring producer.
And in real life, J, the
character, is an extended version of me.
I have my
awkward moments often and I really just like
to find the
humor in simple situations.
Originally from LA.
I don't
know this feels like a dating service.
[laughter] That's me in a
nutshell.
So I hope you pick me.
[laughter]
>> Tracy: Okay.
I'm contestant number 2.
I'm a Gemini.
[laughter] I'm
originally from the East Coast.
Went to Stanford with Issa
and then went to USC film school to pursue,
I guess, a
writing and producing career.
Graduated last year, May of
2010, and linked up to co-produce and write
the show with
Issa.
And I also play the probably most hated character
on the show.
[laughter] Her name is Nina.
She's a bitch;
everyone doesn't like her.
Yeah, so that's me in a
nutshell.
>> Female presenter: What's your real name.
>>Tracy: Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't tell you my name?
I'm Tracy Oliver.
>>Madison: My name is Madison Shockley.
I like long walks on the
beach.
[laughter] I play Fred on the show but in
real life I'm an
entrepreneur, marketer, and just loving life.
[chuckles]
>> Presenter: Great.
So what is Awkward Black Girl?
Where did it
come from?
What's your inspiration?
How did this whole
thing begin.
>> Issa: So as I mention I do have several
awkward moments in
life and I come from a really, really awkward
family.
My
mom is the queen of awkward.
Her moments are ridiculous.
Like as a family, we once walked into the
wrong funeral.
[laughter] And had to leave quietly.
We walked in late
to the funeral.
Things like that and just as a family we
always would laugh at these simple moments
and we come
home and we share these moments together like,
you know.
And something that I thought only we found
funny and then
as I started making friends, we'd share that
humor.
And I
grew up watching shows like The Office and
30 Rock.
I didn't grow up
watching--.
[laughter] But yeah.
I love shows like The Office, Arrested Development,
.
Parks and Recreation.
And that humor just resonated with
me but I felt like once again the humor wasn't
really
present in shows of color.
And so, I felt that void and
I thought that it would be funny to put the
two elements
together.
And so, I decided I wanted to make it an
animated series originally but I just didn't
have the
money to do that.
And so, after, you know, two years of
sitting on the idea, m I read an article in
Clutch magazine
and they were asking where's the black Liz
Lemon?
And I was like, "no, that's my idea; I need
to do it".
[laughter] So instead of
putting the money to do an animated series
I just decided
to shoot it guerilla style.
Called up my friend Andrew, who plays A on
the show, and my best friend, Devyn, to like
--who had no film experience--
I asked her to help me shoot it and that's
how the show
was born.
>> Presenter: That's great.
Who are the inspirations for the
characters.
>> Issa: My pet peeves in life are the inspirations
for the
characters.
I really -- for example the boss lady when
she asks -- in Episode 2 she asks all these
questions about Jay's hair after
it's cut it off.
She said, "Is that how your ancestors
wore it?
Is that why you wear it?" [laughter] And I
actually had a
teacher in sixth grade who asked that if I
wore my hair
naturally because I was honoring my ancestors.
[laughter] And then
like Baby Voice.
Baby Voice, Darius, comes from my pet peeve
of having to ask
people to repeat themselves because I feel
rude asking
you to, you know, I'm sorry I didn't hear
you and they'll
be like.
[laughter] One more time and I'll be like.
[laughter] So things like that.
Different pet peeves in
life, different awkward moments that come
from those
characters.
>> Presenter: Tracy, Madison, where do you
draw inspiration when
you're playing Nina and Fred respectively?
>>Tracy: Nina is pretty much that girl or
guy that everyone has
encountered.
That person on the job that takes their job
too seriously [laughter] or that person who
shows up to class ten
minutes before class starts or the person
in high school
that stays after to ask the teacher questions
and people
are trying to leave.
[laughter] It's -- she's pretty much that
type
A person who is kind of a go getter and that's
something
I guess to admire but she's also -- she's
mean and kind
of vicious and kind of a bully.
And I think, playing her,
I had to draw on those experiences from middle
school.
I
think middle school and high school are the
times in your
life that you feel most like an outcast.
And I try to
think of like the mean girls, the most popular
girls in
high school that pretty much either tormented
me or that I knew.
So it's kind of ironic that I'm playing them
now because
I was not that person at all growing up.
But that's what I try
to channel -- the people that I know and have
encountered
throughout different times of my life that
I couldn't
stand.
[chuckling]
>> Madison: Yeah, Fred is like the guy -- he's
a hard working guy.
He's the guy in the office though that doesn't
really --
is not really aware of the attention he gets
from the
women in the office.
[chuckles] But he's an easy going, nice guy,
hard working, and that's kind of who I am,
in general, too,
so.
>> Presenter: So you are Fred in many ways.
>> Issa: Woo.
[laughter]
>> Madison: In some ways, yeah.
>> Presenter: Do you play the guitar over
your shoulder at home to
practice that?
>>Madison: I did practice that for a week
straight to get it
down.
Almost knocked my head off trying to do it,
too.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: That's great.
So did you set out to make an Internet only
hit or
were there greater aspirations for the show.
>>Issa: Honestly, in putting it out.
I wanted to just expand
my portfolio.
I had two other web series before that.
The second one was sort of gaining popularity
and I
wanted to take advantage of that audience
and you know
once I put out the series I didn't really
-- I didn't
expect for anyone outside my friends and family
to spread
it.
So I didn't have necessarily high hopes for
the web
series but I did have high hopes for the brand
because I
did think awkward and black, in and of itself,
was something different and
wasn't represented.
So I thought the web series would
accompany that brand.
And so, yeah I didn't have high
hopes initially.
So.
>>Presenter: You talked a little bit about
your prior projects.
What were they?
You said two other web series?
>>Issa: Yes.
When I was at Stanford, I created a web series
called, "Dorm Diaries."
Forgot what it was called; Dorm Diaries.
And it was about being black
at Stanford.
And I was trying to like procrastinate
writing a paper one day and I had the idea
to the series
and I just went to the Stanford's library,
went to their equipment, wrote a script
really quickly.
Contacted people like Tracy to be in it.
I wanted to take advantage of Facebook.
Facebook's Posted
Items feature just came out and people were
sharing
articles and YouTube videos.
And I was like how cool
would it be to make a YouTube video for people
to share on campus.
I felt like this would spread and it did.
And people outside of Stanford, like people
at Howard, at
Duke were like, "I really identify.
This is my black experience in
college."
I felt like there was something there.
And so,
my second web series was called FLY GUYS present
the "F" Word.
And it was
just about an LA group trying to make it in
the music
industry.
It was a mockumentary.
And same premise.
That's the first time I started taking the
web really,
really seriously.
Would have like these production
Meetings on Monday where we would sit down
together and
spread the word about the series.
We would put out every
Monday faithfully.
I just started taking the Internet
seriously and YouTube seriously.
>> Presenter: Stanford really is a great place
for innovating ideas
whether it's in tech, in the arts.
Tracy also worked on a
few projects at Stanford; you want to talk
a little bit
about those.
>>Tracy: I did.
I came from like the theater space.
I pretty
much -- which sounds crazy--, went to Stanford
wanting to
pursue theater [laughter] even though people
don't see Stanford like
that.
It's a great place to kind of cultivate a
lot of
artists because there is a lot of grants and
resources
and fellowships that really supported us.
And coming in,
I started this company called Blackstage and
it was a
theater company.
And just through that, we were able to
do original productions that Issa adapted
and directed
and also productions that I would direct and
write and
act in.
I directed the Wiz when I was there.
Did like
a lot of productions.
Vagina Monologues and For Colored Girls, we
both
acted in together.
So we did several productions at
Stanford.
Then when I graduated, I went to USC film
school.
Did a few short films there.
I'm currently
working on feature as well that I'm working
with Morgan
Freeman on.
That's what I do outside of Awkward Black
Girl is I also write.
>>Madison: I kind of came from the opposite
end of the spectrum
as they did.
I dropped out of community college to start
my own business.
Started a recording studio, recording
local artists and doing artist development.
And then
also working for an independent record company
as a
marketing director.
Did a national album release for MLK
records in association with SCLC.
And that's kind of my
background.
>> Presenter: No acting experience for you.
>> Madison: No.
This is my first time acting.
>>Presenter: How are you enjoying it.
>>Madison: I'm enjoying it.
>> Issa: We were in a church play together.
I would like to put on.
Madison likes and I put on one of
my first plays in church and he was in it.
I think he
played Jesus.
[laughter] How dare you.
>> Madison: I've only acted with Issa my whole
life.
[laughter].
>> Presenter: I feel like I should have a
witty thing to say.
I
don't want to get in trouble with Jesus jokes.
[laughter] I already said too much.
So let's move into
our uncomfortable controversial subjects section,
on that
note.
So can you talk a little bit about your decision
to use the N word in the show.
If any thought went into
that, what thought did, and if anything didn't,
what do you think of it in
retrospect.
>> Issa: In creating the show I always say
this but I wanted to
create a character whose raw and unfiltered
thoughts were
put out there, essentially.
And like a lot of the
feedback that we get is people find our show
funny but
they wish we wouldn't use the N word because
they don't
use it and they feel like it's vulgar.
In my mind, I say, like
even if you don't use the word, you've thought
it.
[laughter] If
someone's done something you'll be like this
-- umm.
So
that's a real thought.
Think about it -- J's passion
and what she does in her spare time is she
writes violent
rap lyrics to help her get through things.
[laughter] Just kind of
rap uses that word a lot.
There's so many phrases and sayings
in rap culture that are used.
So naturally J would
embrace that.
I mean -- at the end of the day this is
satire.
It's supposed to be representative of what
real
life is.
Real life is the N word.
[laughter].
>>Presenter: Quotable, right.
>>Madison: That's a t-shirt--
>>Presenter: I was at the Kanye West/Jay-Z
Watch the Throne show last night and they
perform "All of the Lights".
There's a line in there when he
says about Michael Jackson, our N word there.
And he said I
want everybody in the audience to yell this
out.
Black
people give everyone a pass just for right
now.
[laughter] It's
interesting to see how.
>> Issa: That's very interesting.
>> Presenter: The N word continues to evolve.
[chuckles] Plays a role in our
culture.
>>Presenter: So speaking of offensive topics,
there's a recent
Internet controversy with the Feminist Collection
or
Collective which is an online blog or community
which is
LGBT community and they posted an open letter
offended about
the use of the T word which not all of us
knew that it was
offensive to the extent this group found it;
this community found it.
So can
you talk a little bit about your response
and what these new controversies mean to you
in the further development of the show?
>>Issa: Yeah, like as you mention we weren't
aware that the T
word was a slur at the time.
And it's really -- it's
actually odd because the original -- the original
line
was -- oh, I can't even say any of that.
[laughter] But the actress
accidentally said that but we kept it in there
because it
still worked.
But in doing the show, as I mention, it is
satire and it is everyday speak.
A lot of these
characters -- we tackle so many subjects that
many people
consider offensive.
And so, we put that in line.
The
character CeCe, for example, just does questionable
and
says questionable things and that fit in with
her
character.
And in a particular scene, J was going
through sort of like a heartbreak and this
other girl
comes into the picture and CeCe said this
particular
statement to make J feel better.
And when the Crunk Feminist Collective, the
CFC
approached us about it, they wrote a respectful
open
letter.
They're fans of the series.
I wanted to
acknowledge it because they were one of the
first groups
to support Awkward Black Girl in the beginning
when we
had less than 1,000 fans, they were there
promoting the series.
I felt like we owe them at
least an acknowledgment of what they were
saying even
though I didn't necessarily agree with the
fact that we
were targeting them or we were being hateful.
I understood where they were coming from and
why that word could be offensive.
We wanted to say, "hey we
hear you.
We don't mean to offend you, to hurt you but
this is something we struggle with."
We walk this line
every single -- not every day -- every episode.
What's
offensive what's not.
You might want to add to that.
>> Tracy: The irony in the situation is that
when we were in the
writer's room and we're coming up with episodes,
as Issa
just mentioned, we struggle with the issue
of being
politically correct versus incorrect all the
time and
what's appropriate and what's not appropriate.
This
particular word -- T word -- we didn't even
know was any
kind of slur.
It was the one word that we didn't even
debate it because we were that unaware of
its meaning
and the history that it now represents.
We were unaware
of the violent history of that word.
Other times that we
use the N word or we bring up social issues,
it's
intentional.
It's deliberate time we're trying to bring
certain issues to light so we can talk about
it.
And
through certain characters like Sister Mary
being this
kind of like hypocritical Christian and then
Boss Lady
who is really down with black culture but
says really
culturally insensitive things.
Or Amir who is racially
ambiguous so he can insult anybody ask and
get away with it
because nobody knows who he is.
We do these things all
the time.
Sometimes it's inappropriate to certain groups
of people and we're either unaware of it or
we're doing
it to bring those issues to life.
With the T word, it was
just unawareness of it.
Like Issa said now that we are
made aware of it and we realize it was offensive
to the
LGBT community, it's something we're aware
of and we're
not going to do again.
But that was not a deliberate
attempt to demean or cause harm to any member
of that
group.
>> Presenter: The way I look at it you say
a lot of offensive things
on the show.
It's kind of the intent behind it in order
to promote dialogue or promote laughter.
>> Issa: Absolutely.
>> Presenter: Well, let's move onto lighter
subjects [chuckles] and talk a
little bit about heartthrobs.
So where's CeCe?
We had an
audience specifically from one of our fellow
Stanford.
There you are.
Dante in the back.
So where is CeCe since
we know we got a few fans in the audience?
>> Issa: CeCe's chilling at home.
She actually has to work.
But this is so sad Dante.
[laughter] Yeah.
But yeah, she would
love to be here.
She just couldn't.
>> Madison: A lot of people don't know what
CeCe is and she's
Indian.
So I'll clarify that.
>> Presenter: Thanks.
And so, Madison.
I keep wanting to call you
Fred.
How does it feel like to be a heartthrob?
Has your dating helped since being on the
show.
>> Madison: It's helped a little bit.
It's definitely changed since being on the
show.
[laughs] They
do a really good job of making me look good
on the
screen, writing for my character.
Yeah, no -- it's way
different.
In public, people recognizing me.
Want to
take pictures and stuff.
So yeah.
It's a lifestyle
change.
>>Presenter: So people do recognize you in
public?
>> Madison: Yeah.
>>Presenter: That's incredible.
>> Presenter: How about you Tracy?
>> Tracy: Yeah, so I get recognized and usually
it's not a
pleasant experience.
[laughter] Because most people think I'm not
acting for some reason.
So even if I'm with them or with
anybody in the cast they'll be, "Hey Fred!
Hey J. Oh."
And then they just don't even want to speak
or say
anything.
I get the worst side eyes ever.
So I'm not
Nina.
I'm really pleasant and nice in real life.
I get
recognized and I get really serious side eye.
>>Presenter: So J -- sorry Issa -- how did
you learn to rap so
well?
>>Issa: I've always had just a fascination
with rap.
And my
little brother and I -- no -- ever since like
again sixth
grade I tried to start a rap group in every
grade.
[laughter] And
like, I was the only ' bout it one.
And my little brother
and I actually were a duo.
We were a rap duo.
We were called --. Never mind.
[laughter]
>>Presenter: No, no -- continue.
What were you called?
>> Issa: We were called JoLeDi but it doesn't
make sense.
It's our names.
It's the
first letters of our names.
>> Presenter: Is this Enimal?
.
>> Issa: Enimal.
Yeah, my brother and we would rap together.
We had a
song Bang Bang.
It was a hit in the house.
And then
when I went away to college he actually pursued
rap and
got really, really good.
And I got kind of jealous
because we were in this together initially.
And he started
his own rap group.
So I really started focusing and I
just love rap.
I just love hip hop.
I would free style
when I would be under the influence of alcohol.
[laughter] And
since then I just never let it go.
I thought it would be
fun to incorporate this love of rap.
This love of
raunchy, ratchet hip hop into that character.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: Can you do a ratchet rap for
us right now.
>> Issa: CeCe is not here so.
Yeah, she's my beat.
>> Presenter: You need a beat?
>> Issa: Okay.
>> Issa: Yeah, you going to give me a beat?
>>Presenter: [ beatboxes].
>> Issa: Sitting ere at Google.
You all just oogling but I'm just me
and I'm just flowing.
Got my girl Tracy and Madison with
me.
This is real crazy because we're here for
ABG.
And I'm so tough.
I'm
on the mic rough.
And I'm just going to keep going until
you say stop.
Stop!
[laughter] [applause].
>> Presenter: That will be on YouTube later.
[laughter] Thank
you.
>> Madison: You all got a guitar in the house?.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: I think he's going to go get
one actually.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: So why is Awkward Black Girl
successful?
There are a
lot of other shows, web series, that are built
just for
the Internet.
What is it about ABG that you think has
made it take off?
>> Tracy: Sure, I think the thing we hear
most often is that it's
relatable.
I think if you come just from the awkward
point of view, first of all, almost everybody
can relate
to those awkward moments that we touch on
on the show.
Walking down the hallway.
Especially if you work in the
office building.
You see the same people every day and
several times in one day.
[laughter] Do I have to keep smiling and
say hello every time I pass this person?
And it's
awkward for the person that's stationary -- the
receptionist or somebody that keeps having
to see this
person walk past them.
And that's something we can
always relate to.
The thing that Issa and I bond off of
because we're both semi-awkward.
And at Stanford we would
just have these awkward moments happen a lot.
And we
were in the airport recently and had like
another awkward
moment where -- we had one yesterday, too.
Yeah, I'll
just explain this one where we were getting
off the plane
and like the person we got seated next to
was kind of a
celebrity person.
>> Issa: She was on Top Model.
>> Tracy: She was on Top Model and we both
--
>> Issa: Well, this is broadcast.
We don't want her to know that.
>> Tracy: She's on Top Model and we're both
like "Oh, she's on Top Model" and we're talking
about her even
though she's sitting next to me.
Anyway, we got off the
plane and both of us had to go to the bathroom
and then
she was going to the bathroom.
And we both needed to go
really badly.
>>Issa: We'd already said "bye"
>>Tracy: We said bye to her.
[laughter] And we're like bye
girl and we went in separate directions and
realized we
were headed to the same bathroom.
So in order to not
have to see her again, we walked like -- and
extra, like,
mile to the nearest restroom.
Having to go really badly
just to avoid seeing her again because we
said bye.
So
it's like -- so we do these really awkward
drawn out
things all the time just make notes of them
put them in
the show.
You guys can relate to that kind of stuff.
So
it's not even just about race.
It's about like the universal
awkwardness we all go through.
I also think just the
cast being primarily filled with people of
color --
there's not a lot of shows that display us
in those
lights.
Because the thing is, all of us are awkward
and
nerdy and have all these weird quirks about
us, but I
don't really see that.
I see us as being sassy and
really cool and really suave and put together
or really loud or
obnoxious or whatever.
Be we don't really see normal
people that like I went to school with or
that remind me
of my friends and family.
So I think we're showing a
different side of what it's like to be of
color and be
quirky and awkward.
So I think the awkwardness is
relatable.
Just being of color and having that element
adds to it.
>> Madison: I would say it's also successful
because of the spirit
that we have among each other.
And contributing and
helping get things done and move the project
forward.
That's been a big part of the success of our
project.
Because it can be extremely hard.
As probably a lot of
you know to coordinate a lot of people to
work on your
project without any money and without -- and
that's
something that Issa did remarkably.
>> Presenter: Great.
Well, we wish you much continued success on
YouTube and beyond hopefully.
And next we will go into a
screening of episode 5 the party.
[audience member hoots]
>> Tracy: Awesome.
>> Issa: Just sit here?
>> Presenter: It's kind of awkward.
>>Madison: Should we sit down?
>>Tracy: This is awkward.
[laughter].
[music].
>> J: In my mind, I'm the best dancer ever.
[rhythmic
music].
>> Male rapper: [rap] Ice Cube baby, Ninety-nine
baby, I'm on the grind baby, All the time
baby.
Show me something.
You can do it; put your
back into it.
I can do it put your ass into it.
You can
do it put your back into it.
Put your ass into it.
Put
your ass into it.
[rap] tic-tic-boom, hear me banging down these
back streets.
Bumpin' Blackstreet, fiending like an athlete.
Life ain't a track meet, no, It's a marathon.
Fuck the cemetery that a nigga get buried
on.
>>CeCe: [claps hands] J you need to focus.
We need to figure out this
dancing situation.
>> J: [Coughing] You know I think I caught
something from
Patty.
It's not feeling so good.
I'm just going to stay
home.
>> Cece: You're full of shit.
Look, Fred actually invited you tonight.
You've been
trying to get close to him forever.
Here's your
non-stalker's chance to do it.
>> J: Fine.
You're right.
>> Cece: Besides you're not the only person
in the world who
can't dance.
I'm an okay dancer but what makes me a
great dancer?
This.
[demonstrating] [music begins] I whip my hair
back and forth.
I whip my hair
>> J: I hate to say this but hair is the best
thing to
happen to rhythmless non-blacks.
>>Cece: See?
You just work the hair and nobody knows you
can't dance -- oh, right.
Sorry.
>>J: You know what?
Just forget it.
I got him a card.
I'll give it to him at work.
No big deal.
>> Cece: No -- you're giving it to him.
In person.
Tonight.
And then you're going to make out with him.
Get dressed.
We're leaving.
>>J: [heavy sigh]
[slow music]
>>Male DJ: Yeah.
[music picks up rhythm].
>> J: I hate parties.
They're so competitive.
A blatant
contest of luxe, style and sex moves.
I'm so above that.
[music]
>>Cece: There he is.
Go.
>>J: Fred.
>>Fred: J, you made
it..
>>J: I just got you this card.
Not a big deal or anything.
>>Fred: Aw, that's so nice.
Thank-you.
>> J: Is it weird I glued the card shut so
he needed my
help.
>>Nina: Damn girl.
I didn't know Fubu made dresses.
>> J: Nina.
We're not at work.
>> Nina: Well, it's Saturday night.
Have you been taking our
drugs?
>> Fred: I cannot get this card open for nothing.
>>J: Oh.
Just.
You know.
>> Nina: I can help with that.
>>J: Umm --
>> Nina: [reading] Oh, happy birthday, Fred.
Thanks for being the reason
I haven't quit.
[giggles]
>> Nina: That's so cute.
Another work reference.
>> Fred: Thank you, J . Look, look -- grab
a drink.
Enjoy
yourself, okay?
>>Male DJ: [music] She want it, I can tell
she want it
Want me to push up on it 'fore she know when
I'm all on it
We get the party going, liquor flowing, this
is fire
50 and Jeremih, number 1, there's nothing
higher
>> J: Everybody from the office is here.
Why did I think I
was special?
>> Cece: Why is Nina dancing with Fred?
>> J: My comebacks weren't fast enough.
>> Cece: Is she trying to get pregnant?
>> J: Let's get out of here.
This party is lame.
>> Cece: No, it's not.
I'm having a great time.
You need to
loosen up.
Get a drink.
Go dance with some hot guy.
>> J: Thirsty Bitch is dancing with my hot
guy.
>> EnimaL: Hey, what's up.
>> Cece: What's up Papa?
>> EnimaL: I'm enimaL.
>> Cece: I be CeCe.
What it do?
it?
>> EnimaL: It do.
I guess.
>> Cece: That's what's up bud.
That's what's up.
>> EnimaL: Hey, I'm going to get some drinks.
You stay like
right here.
>>Cece: Alright, play on.
>>J: Why does CC sound like a contemporary
slave.
What was that?
>>Cece: Black guys love when I talk like that.
>> J: He walked off.
>> Cece: He's getting his drink, see?
Oh, hell no.
Ruth!
>> J: Great.
Now I'm by myself.
[rhythmic music].
>> J: Standing alone at parties is the clearest
indication
that nobody wants you.
Should I try to make friends?
[rhythmic music].
>> J: Do I need to act like I'm having a great
time?
Are
people looking at me?
Maybe if I dance next to this guy
he'll recognize his urge to dance with me.
>>J: If this party is a competition, I'm losing.
Could
things get any worse?
>> A: I brought you a drink.
>>J: I'm allergic so.
>>A: But you were
drinking the night we passionately made love.
>>J: We did not f-ing make love.
We had sex!.
[loud scratching noise]
>>J: It was a f-ing mistake.
I never want to see you again; I was drunk.
So get out of my
life.
[slaps cup]
>>J: CeCe's right.
I need to loosen up.
>> White Jay: Here.
Let me -- here you go..
>> J: Beautiful.
>>White Jay: You bet
>>J: Awwww, mother f-[beep]
>> White Jay: Beautiful
>>J: What, this stain?
>>White Jay: No, that's I was talking about
the way you said mother [beep]
. I can't do it.
But you had like a melody to it.
It was beautiful.
>> J: Mother f-[beep]
>> White Jay: I'm Jay.
>> J: So am I.
That's so --
>> White Jay: So dyno-mite! [laughs] Okay
because you're Jay and I'm Jay so
it's Jay Jay.
So dyno-mite!
It's Good Times.
>>J: Lame.
So cool.
>>White Jay: It was lame.
I'm so awkward.
>> J: I'm awkward.
Like you don't even know.
>> White Jay: No, you're mother fucking beautiful.
>> Fred: Hey, I see you met my boy, Jay.
>>White Jay: What's up, man?
>> Fred: Yeah.
Well, I'm going to hit the dance floor and
get
my Dougie on.
You all coming.
>>White Jay: I don't dance
>>J: I don't dance
>>White Jay and J: Me, neither
>>White Jay: I just thought though, because
you just seem like.
>>J: Like I have rhythm.
[laughs]
>>White Jay: No, not to be like weird about
it
>> J: It's like a burden for me.
>>White Jay: I just figured you could dance
but not because of any reason.
>> J: Did I just see what I thought I saw?
No way.
Fred
couldn't be.
>> J: It's hot in here.
>> White Jay: Yeah, okay.
>> Male rapper: [music] I think I started
something.
I got what I
wanted -- can't feel nothing [song].
>> Darius: I just wanted you all to say happy
birthday to a man
Fred.
It's his party.
Hey Fred come on up here,man.
You know, when we was in high school, dude,
. We was on the track team.
He made us run[inaudible]
>>Fred: [laughing].
Aw thanks man
>> All: [singing] Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to
you.
Happy birthday dear Fred.
Happy birthday to you.
[applause].
[music starts again]
>> White Jay: So it's a slow song.
You want to give it a shot?
>>J: Sure, why not.
>>Female singer: [song] Even if we only go
to my house.
>>J: Nothing like a cute white guy to make
me feel secure
about my dancing.
Wait, is he looking at me?
Could it
be?
Is Fred suffering from a bad case of envy?
All it
took was a -- I change my mind.
The worst thing about
parties is watching the guy you like kiss
the girl you
hate.
[music]
>> Issa: Is it focused?
It's too dark.
Okay.
We can
turn the exposure up.
>>Friend: Where is that?
>>Issa: I have to show you.
So awkward.
But my mouth is too dark?
I can put it in auto-focus at this point,
too.
>>Friend: This is the view that I have of
you.
Can't really tell.
>>Issa: Can you?
>>Friend: Do you want the view of your radio
too?
>>Issa: No, I just want to start with the
radio with me
turning my song up and then back to here.
Mostly like when I am going to shift
my.
Yeah, when I am like -- as long as you can't
see out
my window that he's not there really.
>> Andrew: I think it's pretty good.
>> Issa: And what about if I'm scooting down?
Can you tell that my seat is going down?
>> Andrew: Yeah.
>> Friend: That's good.
>>Andrew: You can't see me.
Yeah, that's perfect.
>>Issa: Okay, so let me just keep it at this
angle or
whatever.
>> J: Are you coming?
[cracks up laughing]
>>Nina: t Yeah well, look.
My sorors are meeting up later for dinner
if you
want to meet up later.
>> J: You know it's really nice of you.
You know I didn't really eat lunch today
>> Nina: Oh, whoa, -- no, no, no -- I meant
after.
>>Tracy: [as Tracy] Oh no stop.
Why did she
laugh?
>>Loud woman: Uh-huh?
For real?
No.
But let me tell you last
night -- last night.
Was so bomb.
It was like.
Then I
was like yeah.
Uh-uh.
Why doesn't she..
>>Loud Woman: Hello how may I help you.
>> Loud Woman: Yeah, so I was like.
Yeah, let me tell you about last
night though it was on.
It was so on.
Why didn't you go
last night.
Where hold on.
>>J: Can you keep it down a little bit.
>> Loud Woman: Keep it down?
>> J: Yeah, just.
>> Loud Woman: Yeah, anyway so yeah, the hair
appointment?
Lashanie
knee did it?
What did.
[laughs]
[loud traffic noises]
>> J: Oh, I got it.
When I pick up the coffee cup like
this.
[laughter]
>> Person filming: I don't see the coffee
cup.
I see your ass.
>> J: But is it just my ass.
>> Filmer: Well no.
Bend over.
I see all of you.
>>J: Hi.
I'm Jay I'm sorry?
Derek?
>>Darius: [whispering] Darius.
>> J: So are you from around here?
I'm sorry, come again?
>> Darius: Arizona, originally.
>> J: Yeah, oh.
Come again
>>Darius: Arizona, originally
[laughter]
>>Darius: I was upset when he switched.
[inaudible]
[laughter]
>> Darius: My parents sometimes we don't like
jelly fishing.
[laughter]
>>Crowd: Action.
Hey.
Go go go go go go go.
Go crazy.
>>A: I brought you a drink..
>>J: I'm allergic.
>>A: But you were drinking the night we
passionately made love.
>> J: We did not make love.
We had sex! [beep]
>>Woman on stage: So, I said live today like
it is tomorrow.
Yet, I
felt so much sorrow.
But I will not borrow nor buy your
excuses.
[long beep] But I will not borrow nor buy
your excuses..
>>EnimaL: Let's go, Queen.
Nothing but OGs in here anyway
>>Cece: [singing] Good-bye high high high.
High high high.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: That was great.
I don't think I've ever laughed that
hard at work.
>>Presenter: So we'll open up the floor to
questions now.
Anyone
has a question wants to come over to the mic.
Please
don't yell out because we are recording this
for later
and there are people on VC.
Some come on over.
While we're waiting, when
will we find out who J chooses?
>> Issa and Tracy: January 12th.
>> Issa: Episode 12 season finale premiers
and we'll know who J makes; who
decision J makes.
>>Tracy: J makes what [laughs]
[laughter]
>> Female #1: Okay.
Hi I'm Shaniece.
I loved your episode by the way.
I've seen
all your episodes like ten times.
[laughs]But I know that you
did make it -- the webisodes are supposed
to be able to
view them online and everything like that.
But I know
one day I was watching MTV and I saw a show
called
Awkward.
And I thought it was interesting because the
entire cast of course is white.
And I much prefer your
show and I was wondering if in the future
if you're
working towards being like on mainstream or
something
like that do you think the kind of show you
have just
wouldn't fit in and it would limit what you're
trying to
do with your show.
>> Definitely the latter.
It's something Tracy and I
struggle with all the time.
We just went back and forth
with this particular week.
There's definitely interest
in terms of mainstream television, but there's
such a
fear that in selling our rights away we have
to change
the title, the cast, the content.
A lot of it would be
watered down.
That's a big fear of mine in addition to
creative control.
That's very important to us moving
forward.
So personally I feel like keeping it online
and
leveraging our audience, I'm sorry, building
our
audience so we can leverage our position to
networks in the future is the intended goal
right now.
>>Tracy: Yeah, well I would love to see ABG
on television.
I
would love it.
If we could still maintain what we love
about the show -- like, maintain the integrity
of it.
And there are some networks -- cable networks
rather --
that allow you to do controversial topics
and language
like HBO,Comedy Central , Showtime, FX, and
Comedy Central, things like that.
So I think
if we did do television it would have to be
on a network
that allows you to push buttons.
Because I can't see a
format where ABG can exist the same way if
we water it
down to a point where it has to fit a mainstream
audience
and be really PG and family friendly.
Because it's not
that kind of show.
Like Issa said, it's something that we
struggle with.
We we're trying to figure out how to
reach the most mass audience possible but
also maintain
the integrity of the show.
So sorry if that didn't
answer your question.
>>Female #1: No, it did.
Thank you so much and I love you guys.
I'm so glad you're here.
[giggles]
>> Issa: Thank you.
>> Presenter: Yeah?
So we've got some questions people submitted
online.
>>Tracy: Oh, cool.
>>Presenter: Do you want to bring them up
here?
>>Presenter: So after creating ABG, you step
behind the camera to
create the hilarious Fly Guy series.
How have the
creative directive processes differed for
you?
Do you have different
goals and audiences in mind for these two
shows?
>>Issa: So actually Fly Guys before I did
ABG.
At that point I
was really comfortable being behind the camera
and sort
of directing them and the way that show is,
I'll
essentially give them an outline much like
Curbed.
Curbed
I'll give them outline or plot points -- moments
to get
to -- and they'll essentially improvise it
-- improvise a
scenario to come to a certain conclusion.
And so, I love
working with them just because they have a
natural
chemistry and it's just easy.
Whereas ABG is scripted for the most part,
I'm in it, and for the majority of the episodes
I'm directing
myself.
And that's hard because I feel like I'm, like
--
I don't get to focus as much on other actors
because I'm
worried about me.
And I feel like I'm bringing them
down.
If I do focus on other actors I'm not working
on
my own performance.
So I would prefer to have other directors;
it's a little bit
harder.
Yeah, I would prefer either being behind the
camera and directing or being in front of
the camera and
being just an actress.
>> Presenter: That question was from Natalie
Bell who was actually
at YouTube right now.
She's watching.
>> Issa, Tracy and Madison: Oh cool hi Natalie.
>> Presenter: Any other questions?
Come up to the mic and we'll
take your questions as they come.
>>Male #1: How is it going?
Thanks so much.
I started watching
the show this week when I saw your post.
Really loved it
so far.
I wanted to ask -- I'm sorry Nina --
>> Tracy: Awesome.
You can call me that.
[laughter]
>>Male #1: You talk about mentioning the universal
awkwardness of
the show.
I think that's one of the things that's really
appealing.
It's about dating and it's about the office
space.
But then there's also moment unique to being
African-American.
People ask you about your hair.
I'm
wondering what other kind of specific like
unique to
being African-American awkward moments you'd
like to
bring to the show in the future.
>> Tracy: You were asking that?
>> Male #1: Anybody.
>> Tracy: Do you want me?
>> Issa: You can.
>>Tracy: I think episode 7 -- I don't know
if you've gotten
that far in watching but I'll tell you what
that episode
is about.
It's J's character going on her first interracial
date
with a white guy.
For me -- because we co-wrote that
episode together -- and for us to do that
I had to draw
into my experiences with interracial dating.
And just
being African-American woman, it varies.
Like, where you
are.
I'm from the South originally.
And walking around
with someone who's not black -- like, pretty
much elicits
all kinds of stares.
And so, I wanted to incorporate
that into the show.
Even in LA, in places that are more
progressive, there are certain people that
still feel like
interracial dating is something to stare at
or something
to talk about.
So we wanted to kind of make that, I guess,
situation known.
And when they walk into the soul food
restaurant.
It's over-exaggerated, but everybody in the
restaurant turns to them.
We even have a black guy with
a white girl on his arm like -- judging them
as well.
[laughter]
And so, those are the kind of moments where
we are
directly talking about what it's like to be
a black woman
and what it's like to be in an interracial
relationship.
And then also hair is a big -- like you mention
hair is a
big part of the show.
We haven't really delved into like
issues of colorism.
>> J: We're definitely going to go into more
-- after jay
makes decision next season we want to talk
about the
awkward moments of dating as that relates
to I guess
being African-American sort of the standards
that we expect.
So yeah, I
guess to answer your question in terms of
that like where
we'll start figure out.
Because they come every day.
I
don't isolate them as -- oh, this is a African-American
awkward moment.
[laughing] Tapping into that we'll definitely
think
about these experiences.
>> Male #1: Thank you.
>> Issa and Tracy: Thank you.
>>Female #2: Hi.
My name is Camille as an awkward person no
matter
what my race, I'd like to thank you for the
show.
[laughter] Is
there a way to submit ideas?
>> Issa: Currently we can't.
I mean, I guess, legally accept
ideas.
People like will write things in the forum
but
legally we can't accept ideas unless they
come from the
writing team.
>> Female #2: Okay, thank you.
>> Issa: Thank you.
>> Female #3: This is mildly awkward because
the questions I had
they actually both took them.
So.
[laughter] You mention, Issa, that
you thought about and people are like this
is funny but
you didn't think it would be funny beyond
your family and your
friends.
What would you say to those who were in your
shoes -- they were doing things they currently
find funny
between family and friends and they want to
do it but they literally convince themselves
it's not going to be funny.
It seems like your impetus
was when you saw someone else was going to
do it.
And were like
no I got to do it now.
What would any of you, not specific to hear,
say for those who
want to do it but it's just like I just won't
invest the
time.
They've already discouraged themselves.
>> Issa: One of my biggest things is I would
continue make
excuses as to why I couldn't do it.
"Oh, I have a 9 to
5.
I don't have time to do it."
Or "Oh I don't have the
money."
And the more and more I kept saying that I
just
wouldn't create anything.
That was just really holding
me back.
I guess the advice I would give is just to
stop
making excuses.
And if you're really passionate about
something just put it out there.
Doesn't matter if it's
just funny to your family and friends.
Someone else could think it's funny and spread
the word about it.
If you want to put
something out there, there's nothing stopping
you from
putting it out there but you.
I strongly believe in
that.
>>Presenter: Do you still have your day jobs?
>>Tracy: No
>> Issa: No, I quit.
[laughter]
>>Presenter: Congratulations.
>> Issa: Thank you.
>> Tracy: Thanks.
>>Madison: Hold on.
I need a day job.
>> Tracy: I think for me, it's never been
a matter of time in
fitting it in.
Mine has always been fear of other people
judging it.
And that's something I grapple with as an
artist all the time.
Any time I write anything, I'm
always afraid of criticism.
And even with awkward black
girl.
It's been a great experience for testing out
I
guess our work and then also learning to have
thicker
skin and dealing with comments.
The great thing about
YouTube is the feedback is instant.
So you can tell if
someone hates it or loves it within two minutes
of
posting it online.
And that's a good and bad thing.
[laughs]
It's great because you don't have to guess
how you're
doing.
People are telling you.
But it's also -- you
know, bad -- because as an artist, you're
really
sensitive to your work and when you put something
up it's
really hard to hear, "I hated it.
Or this sucks.
You're
terrible at this; you're a bad writer.
You look crazy in this episode."
For
me, because I play the villain, I never read
anything
nice about myself.
It's something I just had to deal
with just like getting over the fear of criticism.
And I
think honestly that's one of the main reasons
why people
are afraid to go after their dreams because
they're
afraid of what people are going to say.
And I think you
just have to do it and take the criticism
if it comes and
take the praise if it comes.
Just learn to get over your
fears and just put it out there no matter
what.
>> Madison: Yeah, I think a major excuse for
people not to start
their great ideas they have is they tell themselves
I'd
do it if I only had this or I had this piece
in place.
I
encourage people to start with what you have
and I think
once you do that our minds can figure out
ways to
accomplish the stuff that's not already in
place.
So it
kind of spurs that creativity.
So go ahead and start.
Figure it out.
>> Female #3: Thank you..
>>Issa: Thank you.
>> Female #4: Can you guys hear me?
I'll just bend down like this.
Hi guys.
My name is Taylor.
Thank you so much for
coming; we are really happy to have you.
I wanted to ask you a question.
As my friends
and I were watching the show.
I think this is more
geared towards Nina's character.
We noticed a lot of references to
sorority life.
And like the satire off of that.
I feel
like you've gotten this question before.
[laughter] I wanted to
know if there were any real life situations
that caused
you to maybe integrate that into Nina's character.
And
also if there are any like pet peeves associated
with
sorority or fraternity life that you kind
of wanted to
highlight on the show.
>>Issa: She wants to know if you're Greek.
>> Tracy: You're trying to get me in trouble.
>> Female #4: No I'm not.
I'm not even in one; totally objective.
>>Tracy: So I'm not either.
For some reason I think people
think because Nina is very much into sorority
life that
I'm into sorority life as well.
I'm not.
Didn't pledge.
I'm not Greek.
But the reason why we put it in there was
because it's a huge part of African-American
culture.
And it's a very big part of going to HBCU's.
It's a big
part of going to any college pretty much at
this point.
There's people that pledge and there's people
that don't
pledge.
So I think we have to have some kind of
character that does represent the Greek community.
As we
do with everything there are moments we are
using satire
to laugh at some parts of Greek life.
In episode 10, that was
that when Nina is hazing the office.
[laughter] That's just an
over-exaggerated like version.
And we combine that with
our Halloween feel to make it really over
the top.
But
we're not necessarily saying anything about
Greeks at
all.
We just think it's important to have some
character
represent that part of black culture.
And it's just fun.
And I do have to share stories.
My sister was at her
best friends wedding reception and her -- my
sister --
the entire, like, bridal party was, like,
in the same
sorority together.
And there was one person who wasn't.
And they like were doing their stroll at the
reception
and she was unaware that you can't just jump
in the
stroll.
[laughter] And so, and she picked up on the
choreography, like, rather quickly and just
kind of like
jumped in.
And they really reacted to it.
And so, that
was something when she told me that -- oh
my God we have
to use that.
And so, we threw Jeremy Patti into my
sorors doing the activity.
What do you think
you're doing.
I thought this was open audition.
[laughter] So
yeah, there's just in a moments.
That was one actual
moment that happened we thought was fun so
we wanted to utilize it.
So yeah --
that's why it's there.
>>Female #5: Thanks.
My name is Shayna.
Thanks again for coming.
We really enjoyed it.
My question is how can we help you
guys move forward?
Remember after you had to push after
Episode 7 to raise money and I'm sure you
need funds to
continue to eat, to make stuff.
So how can we as the
audience help you guys move forward.
>> Issa: Thank you for asking.
>>Issa: We actually have a donate button on
our website.
People have donated after Kickstarter, And
that's really
been helpful.
So if you find it in your heart and your
pocket to donate, go to awkward black girl.com/donate
and
there it is.
>> Presenter: White Jay?
Go ahead.
>> Male #2: Coincidentally my question is
about White Jay
[laughter]
>> Tracy: Love it.
>>Male #2: So does the audience have a -- when
you meet
with the fans and interact with the audience.
Do they
have a preference?
Because you guys have a team Jacob
team Edward thing going here and everyone
I talk to it's
pretty split.
Usually when I see an do you feel
pressure?
First of all is there a certain preference
and
is there pressure writing that in.
>> Presenter: Let's do a quick poll.
Who's team Fred?
Team Fred
hands up.
[laughter]
>>Tracy: You got one.
Two.
Yeah.
There we go.
[laughter]
>> Issa: It's funny she does that.
Initially it was team white
jay.
That wasn't our intention at all.
After episode 5
white jay was only supposed to be a one time
character.
His name was jay at the time.
>> Tracy: The white came later.
>> Issa: And then after episode 5 people were
like "Ooh team
White Jay".
So we're like wow, okay.
This really worked.
And so, the love triangle thing happened really
by
accident.
The audience's feedback.
With that there was
pressure to continue.
I guess you're hired for the rest
of the season.
We worked as writers to put back Fred into
the running, to change things.
So we're happy to say that
not in this room apparently but overall it's
pretty
split.
There's -- there are a lot of team Freds out
there -- teamwhite jays.
Really hostile.
See what kind of
backlash you get.
>>Male #2: Thank you and love the show.
And thank you Janna for
introducing me.
>>Issa: [inaudible]
[cheering and applause].
>>Presenter: [laughter] Sounds like you're
responding real-time to
comments and taking feedback on the go
>> Issa: Yeah we do.
That's what we love about the series.
Instant feedback and you can see how people
respond
about scenarios.
We don't take everything into account
but we do take a lot of things into account.
>>Presenter: We'll go ahead and wrap up this
final question.
Being a YouTube employee
this one caught my eye.
Using YouTube as a platform to
test out a series seems like an obvious way
to gauge viewer
interest.
Do you take into consideration viewer's
comments in creating content and have YouTube
stats
helped you pitch to TV networks.
>>Presenter: You kind of answered the first
part.
Have YouTube
stats helped you in your pitches.
>>Issa: Absolutely.
Stats just help in general.
Even people
to sit and watch the series.
A lot of people -- and I'm
this type of viewer as well.
I'll look at a video and
I'll be like, "this only has 500 views?
Wag."
Without
even testing it.
The fact the show does have a lot of views
or
relatively does help people tune in to paying
attention.
Networks and people have been paying attention.
So definitely the numbers help and the fact
the numbers
are displayed at screen and the likes are
displays really
helps to get us out there.
Through word of mouth, especially.
>> Presenter: Well, it's always exciting to
hear our work is
impacting people's lives individually and
communities
online and off line, in the real world.
With that we'll wrap it up.
There
is a merchandise table in the back if you
guys would like
to pick up some Awkward Black Girl T-shirts.
That's a great way to support the show.
There are
some free ones that we're giving away -- is
that the
case?
Yeah.
So everyone check under your seat.
If you
have a post it under your seat, then you're
getting a
free Awkward Black Girl T-shirt.
>> Issa: Thank you guys.
[Applause]
>> Issa: Thank you.
Tell your friends all about the show..
>> Presenter: Thank you for coming.